the Joe Rogan experience we've talked
about you I don't know how many times
many times I've heard that my son he
says you mentioned my name
glowingly is yeah well hey man you were
a giant inspiration to me when I was
coming up that's good yeah well you know
I've talked about this so many many
times but that era of Boston comedy when
I started in 88 and you guys had already
been through the ding ho and all that it
had been gone and it was the heyday of
comedy it was an amazing time and you
know I was very fortunate to be able to
see guys like you and and Sweeney and
you know and all those guys Mike Donovan
and Kevin Knox and I mean go down the
list over and over and over again Lenny
Clarke just some amazing time for for
stand-up back then yeah that was
certainly the heyday I came in I started
at around 79 and it's been going on for
one or two years but going on meaning
not much going on you know and then it
built and built and built and then to
the point that that explosion was just
it wow it and and I always like to think
people take her to a Boston style
there wasn't a Boston stew other than
being very aggressive maybe yeah there
were but everybody had different ways
don't because we didn't know I wasn't
like an la style
or New York style there was just all
different approaches coming out to the
same man yeah you started 79 so that was
really like the beginning of comedy
clubs right yeah well what they weren't
even coming close
you mentioned the ding hotel used to be
a like a saloon and the guys that were
sitting at the bottom we first went in
there they refused to leave so they
stayed at the boat and all they would do
is when we put someone in on the top
understand you know they'd turn around
and shut the [ __ ] up we're trying to
drink here
we couldn't get we couldn't you remember
so finally we will without because they
get so tired of hearing the microphone
but that was that was just a drink
that's all you can say you know and
became a Chinese restaurant yeah so it
wasn't a Chinese restaurant with us
alone I think you know and
and then suddenly this guy came in it
was approached to put comedy in there
and Barry Crimmins to one of the guys
originally Lenny myself Sweeney as you
mentioned yeah TJ has it people like
that a comedian and tingle yeah it was a
bunch of us that came in at that time
and once again no particular one style
other than the fact that we kind of
created that the headliner would be the
host yeah that was a weird Boston style
like when you have the Don Gavin show
yes you would go out there and host and
you do a few minutes in between each
comic right yeah and well we didn't know
it was weird because I wanted to be in
charge and if Joe we're going on and
slip to the 15 and you do great great
now bill Johnson comes on your blows I'm
gonna go up and take the mic after about
six minutes yeah that was go on to the
next guy yeah and then at the end that
headliner would close the show yeah yeah
that might show it but when you started
doing more and more shows like I started
Knicks in Boston initially it was a joke
it was supposed to be a tax write-off
and they try to sabotage it that used to
be a steak joint really yeah next stage
right and well so we did it one week the
stage was collapsed next week did we no
no sound next week no writing the doors
would be locked and then eventually more
more people coming in then they got
upset because we were getting in the way
of the people going to this distinct
part and then they said well maybe we
can make money on this we'll go upstairs
there was an upstairs there and that was
used only on one night of the week for
Greek belly dances well where they were
paid $200 the next was 200 odd fact they
barely dented the production food they
brought in their own liquor so they only
made $200 for the wicked so once we're
gonna fit on one show then sure and
eventually and around the time when you
came in we were doing five shows my are
my night on Saturday five shows in the
same place upstairs and downstairs yeah
I remember that that was before I was
getting paid so I was really an amateur
but I remember watching
there was a show in the upstairs room
right and then there was a smaller
downstairs room and then there was
another time where they did in the disco
right they have which is a it is a disco
now I write if it is very sad disco well
was sad then too
yes but it was strange that everyone was
cycling from room to room right and you
go from upstairs to downstairs and again
the first one week we tried that with
the first shot you were trying to host
it was it possible to go for party I
mean did the guy in the side of stage
was going you're supposed to be on
downstairs and go every just I just
started up here and it was so confusing
that you get on stage and you say good
evening ladies and gentlemen how are you
I've already said that it gets to the
point and also with a few drinks
involved by the fifth show yeah there
was some repetition sometimes
[Applause]